tu dois être extrêmement triste
forcément
je suis assez choquée mais en même temps
j'étais au courant de la situation et de
l'état de l'État médical de ma
belle-mère c'est juste qu'en fait je
crois énormément à la spiritualité à
Dieu et au signe je suis parti à Cannes
pour faire la montée des marches donc
hier je suis arrivé et je suis arrivé à
Nice et je montrais un de mes assistants
j'ai tu vois c'est là où Tina habiter à
Saint jean-cap-ferrat et je lui raconter
un peu les anecdotes à 4h du matin ou on
avait viré tout le monde parce que elle
est un peu comme moi elle a pas vu ma
vie
et on cherchait une bouteille de
champagne on n'arrivait pas à boutique à
ouvrir la bouteille de champagne et je
racontais donc cette anecdote
juste au moment où la voiture arrive et
je reçois donc un message yo mob un
autre spasoé donc je n'ai pas cru parce
qu'il y a souvent des des sales blagues
et c'était quelqu'un de long de très
proche de Tina donc qui l'a su même
avant enfin jusqu'en il y a eu les
l'équipe médicale qui était au courant
qu'elle est qualité décédée donc on a
pris ça au moment où à 20h à 20h35 et je
parlais d'elle à 20h 20h15
tu es encore en contact avec elle ou pas
oui mais il y a des choses que je peux
pas spécialement dévoiler c'est à dire
que son état médical elle savait plus
enfin je peux pas trop maîtriser par
respect mais tu étais en bon terme avec
elle enfin c'est-à-dire que on avait
beaucoup de similitudes au niveau du
caractère et donc il y a que moi qui
pouvait accepter dans cette famille
parce que les robes en cuir les
hurlements et les cassages d'assiette
faisait partie du menu chez les Turner
donc c'était parfait pour moi j'étais
vraiment accepté alors
pour résumer Tina Turner en quelques
mots pour les plus jeunes qui nous
regardent tu dirais quoi
je dirais déjà en premier lieu c'est ma
belle-mère donc je suis là pour lui
rendre hommage et merci pour votre
invitation merci Cyril et groupe c'est
toujours ma vitesse et ensuite c'est
bien évidemment la plus grosse icône du
rock n' roll et puis surtout ce soir je
suis ici pour lui rendre hommage pour
l'icône qu'elle est mais également en
tant que belle fille parce que j'ai
perdu mon mari également le 8 décembre
donc recteurner son premier fils que
j'ai retrouvé avec un gun un pistolet
dans la tête où j'ai dû casser la
fenêtre ensuite ça a été Roni ça fait
beaucoup Tina n'était plus vraiment la
médicalement donc on était plus trop en
contact parce que elle elle était sur
sous enfin voilà sous traitement donc ça
a été un choc mais je suis là pour
respecter son nom pour continuer la
legacie de high qui est inattender qui
est quand même l'inventeur du
rock'n'roll des producteurs et mon
beau-père et ma belle-mère qui est
décédé hier donc
votre première rencontre parce que quand
vous rencontrez Tina Turner faut que
vous le sachiez
même les même les gars etc sont à genoux
devant ton père la première rencontre
quand tu t'es dit je vais rencontrer
Tina Turner raconte-nous ta première
rencontre alors il faut savoir que Tina
Turner était déjà une star à 16 ans avec
Fally quand elle a elle a elle a
collaboré avec le groupe de high Turner
c'est une dame qui arrive de Tennessee
black américaine il y avait la
ségrégation etc elle a step up son game
en allant avec mon beau-père qui a le
Turner et de là est devenu I can Tina
Turner quand je vais rencontrer pour la
première fois c'était à l'hôtel Bel Air
c'était en 2007 j'avais épousé donc son
fils l'unique fils de hik et Tina Turner
je l'ai connu enregistrement quand
j'enregistrer une chanson qui s'appelait
French Kiss voilà le mec qui était
l'ingénieur était acteur junior était le
fils de Ike d'accord donc je vois ce
grand
garçon arrivait on me dit c'est le fils
de akétina et ça love your son
il a joué l'abeille sur mon titre
on s'est échangé numéro il m'a appelé à
plusieurs reprises je ne voulais pas
trop être dans la relation parce que
c'était quelqu'un qui était très rock'n
roll donc j'avais un peu peur je sortais
une relation déjà un peu rock'n roll
avec Julio et Mike Tyson donc je ne
voulais plus et puis on est devenu amis
pendant un an et finalement le jour de
mon anniversaire il m'a demandé en
mariage donc voilà l'histoire avait
chroniqueur
au début non je ne voulais pas mais moi
je veux toujours je dis toujours non au
premier lieu et après je dis oui et ben
voilà Daniel aussi elle dit non promis
hôtel ça a pris 30 minutes pour qu'on
puisse se regarder j'ai commandé un
verre de champagne frozen un verre de
vin et des côtes d'agneau elle a
commencé et commander la même chose elle
m'a dit what is you planes c'était la
phrase de fou sur tinder on a vraiment
la bonne personne Afida avec nous ce
soir c'est une carrière incroyable et
elle a inspiré de nombreuses stars
regardez même Beyoncé durant des hommage
en 2008 regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la reine du rock n' roll pour ceux qui
ne la connaissaient pas ou ceux qui la
connaissaient qui ont envie de regarder
c'est plus grand tube on vous a préparé
une compil regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle avait également été choisie pour le
générique de Golden Eye witness
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous a donc quitté à 83 ans des suites
d'une longue maladie dans sa maison
située à Zurich en Suisse Gillain
absolument elle vivait ensuite avec son
mari allemand depuis un long moment et
puis elle avait cette longue maladie
dont elle ne parlait pas énormément elle
était très discrète là dessus et je
comprends qu'affilée soit discrète
effectivement elle s'était en Suisse ça
fait longtemps qu'elle était malade oui
elle était malade depuis un bon moment
son mari d'ailleurs il y a quelques
années lui avait donné un rein alors en
2000 exactement en 2017 elle a eu un
rein qui est qui est malheureusement ne
fonctionnait plus et donc son mari Erwin
lui a donné un rat ensuite elle a eu un
cancer du colon mais qu'ils ont pu
justement
calmer et suivre immédiatement mais elle
restait en Suisse elle n'était plus aux
États-Unis elle habitait beaucoup donc
dans le sud de la France et ensuite en
Suisse et
donc voilà but cheese aways looking
beautiful elle est toujours très belle
et même là elle avait 82 ans elle était
toujours magnifique alors elle a démarré
sa carrière dans les années 50 aux
États-Unis elle a remporté 8 granny la
plus huit garmises à la plus haute
récompense de de la musique américaine
elle avait quatre enfants donc Craig
Turner c'est ça en fait il y avait que
deux enfants avec
au Player et on a eu créateur qui est
décédé j'ai retrouvé d'ailleurs mort
dans la salle de bain ça a été un choc
énorme ça fait beaucoup pour moi les
deux enfants juste les deux adopter
exactement
d'une relation précédente avec Junior
exactement et elle a adopté ses deux
enfants voilà donc c'était quatre
enfants et d'où votre ex-mari c'est
Véronique Turner qui décidait lui
décembre malheureusement ça fait
beaucoup il y a eu Coolio il y a eu
Ronnie et là maintenant Tina en six mois
ça fait beaucoup surtout qu'à chaque
fois je retrouve les corps etc c'est pas
facile à gérer c'est très choquant des
gens imaginent Afida Turner elle est
toujours à pied elle a toujours le Power
et maintenant quand vous retrouvez des
gens par terre avec du sang partout
c'est catastrophique j'ai toujours été
quand même une sorte de maman pour pour
Ronnie et pour Craig puisque matinale a
été âgée peut n’était pas là c'était une
Roxane et moi j'étais aux États-Unis
j'avais une très très bonne relation
avec reg bah voilà le voilà créer mon
beau-frère qui était fantastique erroné
alors elle divorce de son mari en 78
après avoir subi plusieurs années de
violence conjugales
c'est mon beau-père ce qui s'est passé
c'est que high Turner était un homme
très généreux il a sorti Tina de la
merde et a fait d'elle une super star
très en plus tard il a commencé à faire
de la chanson elle est à Londres faire
des titres avec Mick Jagger il a
commencé à faire des substances et comme
Tina était une femme avec beaucoup de
caractère il se battait et effectivement
il y a eu des des malheureusement des
violences conjugales ce qui arrive
énormément aux États-Unis et ce qu'il ne
faut pas pardonner mais effectivement
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui s'est passé et
d'ailleurs elle a le courage de le
quitter et de revenir tout de suite
pendant 10 ans elle a galéré elle
faisait les clubs elle faisait les les
casinos à Las Vegas et grâce à Dieu la
rencontre un super manager et est venu
ce titre incroyable qui est watch love
get you et là abra abracadabra alors on
va dire parce que j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure mais son premier fils Craig se
suicide en 2018 avec une arme ça c'est
oui oui c'était un un fils qui était
extrêmement fragile et se suicide à
bouleverser tout le monde je reste juste
revenir à propos de ail qui a eu quand
même à fila énormément de mauvais
traitements abus violences conjugale
elle était plusieurs fois aux urgence
pas parce que moi je lui parle latina
elle me dit et elle dit dans les
interviews à changer ma vie il m'a
jamais touché pendant 15 ans et
effectivement quand il a commencé à
faire de la cocaïne et devenu un homme
très violent et je le quitte mais il
faut quand même redonner le crédit moi
je suis une fille qui est très très très
à cheval sur les principes c'est un
garçon avec un honneur qui était
l'inventeur du rock et qui a sorti Tina
qui a fait d'aller une superstar roll
rolls contrat tout elle a jamais eu à
galérer effectivement quand il a pris
des substances c'est devenu un homme
violent
ça a été un enfer pour elle on peut pas
voilà pas lui excuser exactement on
excuse pas d'ailleurs elle est partie et
d'ailleurs il s'est excusé alors donc
c'est ce qu'elle a eu par contre je
comprends pas pourquoi il y a écrit ex
belle-fille c'est ça exactement c'est
pas ex-belle-fille c'est belle fille
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont cons comme
des pendules merci
son deuxième fils Rony qui est resté
près de 20 ans donc avec Afida et
d'essai il y a quelques mois d'un
concert du côlon à seulement 62 ans à
FIDA donc c'est vrai que comme je dis
elle a vécu beaucoup beaucoup de grammes
dans sa vie
je pense que c'est un peu le revers de
la médaille c'est ce qu'elle me disait
d'avoir eu cette carrière qui est
incroyable et finalement de de pas
toujours avoir pu être présente parce
que c'est une rockstar elle pouvait pas
s'occuper spécialement de ses enfants et
finalement d'avoir eu
crack s'est mis une balle dans la tête
déjà ça ça la ça l'a complètement
traumatisée attristé pourquoi il était
ironie pardon il est son fils était dans
une telle détresse souffrance c'est à
dire que les enfants de stars sont
souvent seuls et ils aimeraient vivre la
vie de leur maman et elle était mariée
avec un homme qui est beaucoup plus
jeune qui est en allemand et elle est
pas là spécialement pour aller au cinéma
avec son fils elle préfère avec son mec
et ça les enfants les enfants ont du mal
à supporter quand les mamans sont des
supers Rockstar ils veulent être dans la
dans la villa ils veulent conduire la
Rolls et elle leur dit vous êtes grand
maintenant vous devez faire votre vie et
pour moi Craig était un mec fantastique
c'est un très bon beau-frère mais de
l'avoir trouvé sur le sol avec le Gun
enfin le pistolet tout moi c'était très
traumatisant j'ai failli me retrouver en
prison parce que j'ai dû casser la
fenêtre appeler la police aux États-Unis
c'est très compliqué
donc vous êtes arrivés vous l'avez
trouvé comment en fait j'avais pas de
nouvelles depuis deux jours j'ai reçu
plusieurs messages il m'a dit viens
chercher le chien ben je lui dis que par
un Vegas et quand je suis arrivé par la
fenêtre j'ai vu son portefeuille et les
clés et il répondait pas donc j'ai cassé
la fenêtre
Ronnie était en train de le chercher
dans le jardin et quand je suis arrivée
dans la salle de bain j'ai vu là j'ai
commencé à hurler ouais ouais my god
pendant au moins 20 minutes les gens qui
tremblaient et là j'ai dû appeler la
police la police m'a gardé au moins
pendant 5 heures parce que j'avais cassé
la fenêtre et voilà était quelqu'un de
très spirituel également j'ai de la
chance j'avais des très bon très belles
très belles très bonne famille les fils
de Tina était fantastiques avec moi
elle était à Paris au festival
something bad will just
de grâce c'est très très fin quelque
chose de grave vient d'arriver est-ce
que tu es assise est-ce que tu es bien
elle était au défilé d'Armani à Paris et
voilà enfin comme on annonce était
compliqué
à Paris mais ensuite effectivement
c'est vrai que quand Rony votre votre
mari ensuite est décédé il y a quelques
mois d'un cancer du côlon à seulement 62
ans ça aussi ça a été un drame que vous
avez dû vivre ensemble c'est un drame
parce que je l'amenais chez le médecin
tous les mois parce que je l'avais fait
arrêter de boire et j'avais toujours
peur en fait qu'il y a vous savez les
gens qui boivent pas avoir une cirrhose
donc je faisais des contrôles
systématique il avait rien et deux
semaines où je suis parti en France
quand je suis arrivé il avait un ventre
comme un comme un comme un ballon de
rugby et il m'a dit ah non mais quand
t'es pas là comme tu fais pas la cuisine
je mange que du McDo et je bois du coca
je l'ai attrapé je l'ai amené aux
urgences aux États-Unis ça prend très
très longtemps donc pour faire un
scanner ça a pris 6 jours pour avoir les
résultats on a eu le résultat on devait
commencer la Chine le 12 il est décédé
le 8 donc j'ai eu zéro chance zéro
chance ça a été une tragédie
c'est vous qui c'est encore vous qui
avez annoncé
toute seule
junior et Michael sont encore en vie
mais n'avait plus aucun lien avec Tina
Turner avec Junior et Michael c'est elle
a ensuite adopté les deux fils de son
ex-mari donc high Turner et par contre
il n'avait plus de nouvelles du tout non
plus du tout c'était ils étaient plus du
tout en contact avec leur mère moi je
suis en très bonne relation avec hack
junior qui était qui était l'ingénieur
voilà qui a eu le Grammy's de acturner
qui est là mon beau-père I Love You Ikea
et ouais non ils sont plus en contact
mais moi j'ai toujours en contact avec
eux et c'est vrai que c'était difficile
pour les enfants parce qu'elle est
partie et puis et puis voilà quoi c'est
le dernier Grammy qu'il a eu qui était
d'ailleurs mixé par acteur junior et il
est décédé juste à moi après donc
j'étais contente qu'il ait eu son
grammise
de blues grand musicien internat
l'inventeur du rock
François a repris les Claudettes
l'inventeur du rock n' roll c'est fort
ça Afida donc ta première rencontre avec
Tina Turner qui nous a quitté hier ça
s'est passé comment qu'est-ce qui t'a
ton mari donc Ronnie il te dit quoi il
te dit je vais te présenter ma mère
comment ça s'est passé ah non ça se
passe pas du tout comme ça c'est la
secrétaire qui appelle et on veut voir
Hafida non ah oui
on vous dit Tina Turner soit de vous
voir voilà très bien et donc alors et
donc elle m'aime bien chez elle à
jean-cap-ferrant voilà c'est les bonnes
années donc là vous y allez vous êtes
stressé non parce que je l'avais déjà vu
au bel air hôtel d'accord comment
croiser le dîner on a fait le dîner
qu'est-ce que tu veux je vais pas
demander d'argent je dis management est
représentation sur ces waouh chez Just
Like Me elle est comme moi tu me dis
tout le monde me demande de l'argent une
voiture toi tu demandes juste un manager
c'est vraiment un bon signe et donc vous
l'aviez rencontré avant d'être avec son
ah non non la première non non je l'ai
rencontré quand elle a su j'étais avec
Rony
hôtel elle a voulu m'inviter à dîner et
elle m'a invité ensuite au concert
d'accord voilà vous a dit elle était
sympa vous aimez bien on était contente
oui on était juste comme ça main dans la
main
elle me donnait la main vous devez tous
te tais-toi
enfin on est resté comme ça toute la
nuit
deuxième fois que vous la voyez donc là
c'est à la maison
à 3h du matin on vire tout le monde il y
a plus qu'à les mois et on cherche elle
cherche une bouteille de champagne on
n'arrive pas à l'ouvrir on a viré tout
le monde de la table et on est resté à
parler jusque 7 heures du matin voilà
magnifique c'était une relation forte
c'est quelqu'un qui dit exactement ce
qu'il pense elle dit qu'elle pense elle
est du elle est elle est franche elle va
dire je t'aime pas je t'aime bien tout
le monde se tais elle est très suivez
votre carrière ou pas du tout oui bien
évidemment parce que j'ai failli enfin
on devait signer elle m'a invité à
chanter vous avez pas les photos
pourtant je elles sont sur elles sont
sur mon Instagram si vous pouvez montrer
elle m'a invité à chanter prime Mary
pendant inside édition d'ailleurs c'est
sur mon Instagram à la Régie si vous
pouvez montrer la photo de moi et Tina
et Rony en train de chanter c'est quand
même inside ils vont la trouver
direct à la télé
sur ton Instagram
et donc j'ai chanté avec elle et voilà
c'était fantastique on a chanté prime
Marya engueuler Tina Turner voilà tu dis
ouais est-ce que tu avais vu par exemple
dans Secret Story non non c'était loft
moi je suis avant garde
les gens on lui disait qui j'étais et
ben voilà voilà c'est fort j'avais pas
répéter j'ai dit OK dans le dos tu
chantais bien absolument elle a entendu
Étienne
et elle aurait beaucoup aimé non mais
c'est vrai c'est complètement saccable
et donc et donc elle est déjà arrivé
qu'elle t'engueule qu'elle te dise ouais
j'aime pas aimer que tu as fait ce que
non c'est moi qui l'ai engueuler
on est au mois de décembre les
Sagittaires et les Capricorne on se dit
ce qu'on doit se dire alors qu'est-ce
que
vous voyez l'icône la star moi j'avais
une relation où c'était c'était la mère
de Rony et de Craig moi je passais tous
les anniversaires tous les je n'ai
jamais loupé un anniversaire de mon mari
je revenais de chez toi
ou de de mes émissions je faisais
l'anniversaire je faisais les Noël avec
Craig donc j'étais tout le temps là pour
eux donc je pouvais me permettre de lui
dire ce que je voulais et personne ne
peut vous dire quoi que ce soit sur moi
et donc
tu l'engueulais sur quoi tu peux me dire
tu aurais pas sur toi
tu peux tu peux pas dire
c'est quoi c'est quoi la dernière fois
que tu l'as tu dois parler
quand mon mari est décédé mais je peux
pas trop rentrer en étant tu pouvais lui
elle peut pas appeler qu'elle pouvait
pas appeler quelqu'un enfin c'était
c'était un peu compliqué
j'ai la jambe qui tremble et donc il y a
eu ça mais c'était un peu compliqué et
puis ensuite non mais quand tu l'as vu
la dernière fois voilà malheureusement
malheureusement
après avoir retrouvé le fils de Craig
afin le corps de Craig
et d'avoir enfin à l'enterrement voilà
voilà
c'était donc c'était trois juillet aux
États-Unis ça prend beaucoup de temps
pour les funérailles c'était en octobre
ça apprend ses apprend à moi on garde
les corps c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que la France elle était déjà malade
mais elle a quand même fait le voyage
mais elle pouvait pas trop voilà et la
dernière fois que tu l'as vu donc
c'était à long terme voilà
donc c'est un souvenir compliqué c'est
quoi le dernier bon moment que tu as
passé avec ordinateur
malheureusement c'était au funérailles
de sa sœur de ses démons Aline sa sœur
sa sœur favorite ou là elle est restée
un peu avec moi elle était elle était
moins malade donc on a passé un bon
temps un bon moment on est allé dîner on
a passé la soirée ensemble ensuite à
l'hôtel et voilà la situation était
triste mais on a on a on a passé la
soirée et le dîner ensemble mais les
meilleurs moments avec Tina c'était à
Saint-Jean-Cap-Ferrat quand on a fait
les 15 jours de vacances est-ce confie à
toi quand vous passiez des soirées
toutes les deux avec les bouteilles de
champagne elle se confie à toi
elle te disait que sa vie n'avait pas
été pas qu'elle a eu elle a eu quand
même une vie très compliquée elle t'en
parler elle me dit que c'est des bus ont
été très très bien très simple mais
qu'elle a payé le prix parce qu'après il
a complication avec son mari et que son
mari était était le producteur en fait
donc il contrôlait tout donc elle devait
elle devait faire tout ce qui lui
demandait de faire mais elle
reconnaissait la chance qu'elle avait
parce que tout le monde à l'époque
voulait être chanteuse pour Alex Turner
ou se marier avec aurner voilà et elle
disait qu'ensuite bon elle a quitté mais
que elle avait toujours de l'amour et de
la considération parce que il avait
sorti de sa mère malgré tout est-ce que
te donner des conseils oui elle t'a
donné quoi comme conseil
il est comme son père
c'est un des conseils et professionnels
parce que elle te donnait quoi comme
conseil elle t'a dit donner des conseils
tu as dit professionnellement elle elle
trouvait très forte que j'ai fait tout
ça toute seule elle m'a dit parce que
moi j'avais hâte tout à fait tout ça
tout seul mon fils a un super musicien
et en fait en en 2009 elle m'a dit jouer
de signer ton album pas parce que tu es
ma belle-fille ce que j'ai même pas
signé mon fils juste parce que tu es une
gold Giler c'est à dire une fille qui va
chercher les trucs elle m'a dit respect
elle te dit que tu avais du talon
j'avais une paire de couilles incroyable
avant
ça rigole pas ça rigole pas ça rigole
pas
hier quand tu as appris que ça ça
disparition
comme tu t'es tu nous as dit tu es un
peu
en arrivant au festival ou je parlais
d'elle et en train de montrer là-bas
pour toi ça a été compliqué
en fait sur le moment j'étais choquée
effectivement j'ai pleuré ensuite je
savais qu'elle était déjà souffrante et
je me suis dit bah en fait voilà il y a
un an je dis il y a quelque chose parce
que j'ai parlé d'elle à ce moment-là et
exactement 27 minutes après j'ai le
message donc je pense que quand je suis
arrivé à l'aéroport de Nice et qu'elle
habitait à côté son âme était là
puisqu'elle habitait 30 ans et que
c'était une façon de me dire au revoir
c'est moi je suis très spirituelle et je
crois à fond à Dieu parce que je serai
jamais là où j'en suis voilà
mais là je suis là pour rendre hommage à
la à l'icône Tina Turner à ma belle-mère
et puis de continuer continuer à
respecter le nom de hackettena Turner
avec mes chansons avec mon courage et
les honorer parce que j'ai le sentiment
d'avoir été choisi par cette famille et
continuer la legacie Turner voilà et
alors
non mais c'est pas fini
c'est bien vous faites un peu d'humour
elle était extrêmement
riche oui plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros on parle d'un héritage
qui serait en estimé ce n'est qu'une
estimation entre 250 et 400 millions
d'euros voilà reste à savoir comment
c'est héritage va être réparti et là
c'est la grande question entre 250 et
400 millions d'euros voilà alors la
grande question c'est si elle résidait
en Suisse elle s'était mariée en 2013
avec un Allemand et les aider à Zurich
si c'est le droit suisse qui s'applique
à ce moment là l'héritage va au mari et
aux deux enfants qui restent les deux
enfants adoptés voilà et aux autres
personnes uniquement s'il y aura une
mention sur un testament ça c'est le
droit suisse s'applique alors
effectivement il a une chose qui est
complètement correcte
quand tu es marié en Suisse c'est une
loi qui est différente je crois qu'à peu
près 47% qui va à l'époux et le reste
aux enfants mais comme les deux enfants
de Tina donc Craig et Rony elle n'a
jamais reconnu elle n'a jamais adopté à
junior qui est mon beau-frère c'était
juste parce qu'elle était avec Ike et
qu'ils étaient dans la famille donc ils
ne sont pas du tout elle les a jamais
adoptés
donc les seuls Bloods comme on dit le
seul sang les descendants de Turner
était Craig et Rony et aujourd'hui j'ai
le sentiment et je suis la seule avec le
nom Turner puisqu'il n'y a plus
d'auteurs et c'est pour ça que j'ai
vraiment envie d'honorer ce nom et de
respecter mes beaux-parents et mon
Ronnie et Craig alors
la loi suisse et j'en suis désolé Hafida
la loi suisse ne reconnaît pas dans ces
cas-là la belle-fille veuve
c'est pour ça j'ai bien compris
on m'a jamais rien donné
est-ce qu'à un moment tu l'as pas dit
j'aimerais faire tel télé est-ce que tu
peux m'aider à faire signer est-ce que
tu peux m'aider à faire ça à rencontrer
telle ou telle personne jamais
c'est-à-dire qu'elle m'a il y a eu un
contrat qui devait être fait quand elle
a écouté mec miser et French Kiss il y a
des choses que je ne peux pas vous dire
qui sont d'ailleurs
bon pour moi c'est ça joue en ma faveur
je ne pourrais pas vous le dire belle
vous m'avez beaucoup plus aidé à
m'inviter sur C8 merci d'ailleurs ça me
fait plaisir oui vous m'avez toujours
invité à chanter mes chansons c'est vite
à passer mon clip non j'ai pas demandé à
ma belle-mère fais-moi un chèque de demi
on ça n'existe pas
et non mais non mais
l'album en 2009 et j'ai fait tout toute
seule voilà je ne suis pas là pour
parler de la fortune de ma belle-mère
parce que j'aimerais respecter son deuil
chez Afrique non bah non non
vous avez dit il y a des choses que j'ai
faites qui jouent à ma faveur qu'est-ce
que
elle trouvait que j'avais beaucoup de
choses
je ne peux pas dire voilà qu'est-ce que
vous aurez aimé lui dire à Tina Turner
que tu lui as jamais dit je lui ai tout
dit
je peux pas vous dire on a toujours eu
un côté des rapports assez privé voilà
non c'est vrai que j'aurais j'aurais
voulu j'aurais voulu qu'elle soit plus
proche de ses fils et j'aurais voulu
qu'on passe plus de temps et j'aurais
voulu que qu'elle soit plus aux
États-Unis mais ça c'est un fait c'est
comme ça c'est pour ça que tu l'as tu la
bousculé un peu quand tu me dis je
l'engueuler un peu parfois c'était pour
ça
je suis là pour rendre hommage à ma
belle-mère je rentrerai pas dans les
dossiers familiaux mais bon voilà
respect tu as envie de l'avoir plus non
pas moi j'aurais je sais pas moi j'étais
pas la mère de craie ironie quoi à un
moment donné je devais t'imagine
retrouver des corps des enfants faire
les entendre moi j'en peux plus quoi
c'est trop dur c'est trop dur c'est
compliqué moi j'ai déjà eu beaucoup de
souffrance en tant qu'orpheline ce que
je dois aussi porter tous ces raconter
ton histoire ah ben la connais par cœur
bien sûr
c'est pour ça qu'elle trouvait que
j'étais très courageux mais là le
problème c'est pas moi je suis pas ici
parler de moi je suis venue ici pour
rendre hommage à la belle-mère et Nikon
et continuer la Legacy du nonturneur et
l'Honoré